young and broke you're not alone they
told us you work hard you get an
education and you'll get a good job but
they were wrong we're facing limited job
prospects the cost of living in
America's cities has skyrocketed and
we're up to our eyeballs in student debt
today those same schools cost more than
nine thousand dollars and private
schools are a whole nother story and do
days worth nothing have nothing to show
for my degree or have nothing but a huge
amount of debt
some have managed to find innovative
ways to get by 38% of us work as
freelancers in the gig economy piecing
together multiple jobs at the same time
what if I work at Costco giving out free
samples of like kale chips but then I
also walk dogs and I'm a yoga teacher at
the same time is that gonna be hard for
me to save money well but even as
millions struggle to cope with student
debt the mega-rich continued to siphon
billions through tax evasion schemes
step 1 set up a large corporation with
millions if not billions in revenue
preferably in tech energy all
pharmaceuticals bubbles happen when
speculators get rich selling things that
turn out to be worth much less than they
claim so join a j+ over the next few
weeks as we take a closer look at how
our generation is coping with a crappy
economy